Let's go to the phones at (617) 830-4750 starting
today with our caller from the nine zero four
area code color from nine zero four.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi there, my name is Sam and uh, I'm calling
you.
Uh, I said the question, uh, and the comment
about, uh, a source of prompts of orders.
I think a lot of Trump supporters come from
fossil fuel, English three in States like
Oklahoma.
And so because of his economic policies, which
reduce regulation and they build those, uh,
several businesses to have grieving for meats
and such life.
But yeah, that'd be like the term Cobert than
the off in the media.
Sam, do you have me on speaker phone?
I'm curious.
No,
you don't.
Okay.
Cause it sounds like chaos.
Listen, I don't, I don't know that the,
so I think a local Trump supporters come from
[inaudible]
yes, yes, yes.
Not talks about, they talk about his nasty
personality and his clothes in character,
but I think the spoke of the economic,
yeah.
I just don't know that the number of people
working in those industries is so large that
it explains the support for Trump.
I mean, there's people that work in fossil
fuels, uh, in all sorts of parts of the country.
Certainly it's a bigger thing in certain States
that have large oil reserves.
But I, I just don't know that that industry,
that that industry is workers.
I think that the influence of the industry
donating to Trump is significant.
I don't know that the fossil fuel workers
were really as big of a piece of it.
I've worked in fossil fuel industry for a
few years and I've noticed, I talked a lot
of people and they, uh, almost Kevan animosity
and K through two are Democrats who they think
they will take their jobs and their view comp
the Lord and savior.
Yes, that's true.
Sometime
this year than wrong, not supported by evidence,
but I think people always believe this.
That's all.
I'm a longtime listener.
I really appreciate your intelligent and thoughtful
analysis, but I wanted to bring this to your
attention,
Sam.
I appreciate it.
Where, where are you from originally, Sam?
Oh, okay.
I was born in Russia, but I became American
citizen in 2013.
Lived in us for like 20 years.
Beautiful.
All right, Sam, I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you.
All right, take care there, Sam